i saw you guys walking around the fans
were asking me to take photos with you
does it feel like it's been 25 years it
really doesn't i mean we feel like i
mean we've looked around we've been in
the bahamas bahamas together disney we
just got
back from epcot we're having a blast and
can't believe that in a blink of an eye
we're here 25 years later it's crazy ask
my niece after the show if it feels like
it's been 25 years
you're feeling 25 years okay so good
with the choreo
yeah well you pull it off you you guys
always look good when you're up there um
is there any advice or piece of wisdom
that you know now that you wish you knew
when you first started
i mean i think in general our you know
looking back
i wish we would have taken it a little
less seriously and just had more fun
like smell the roses a little bit more
along the way um i mean we're fortunate
that 25 years later we're still able to
do it but you know all the amazing
experiences we've had the people that
we've been able to meet um you know just
being able to take a step back and
really appreciate it for what it is when
it's happening i love how this whole
group formed because jeff you started
this you had different members they
eventually left and then you know these
guys came on board do you still talk to
the original members i still do you do
but it it's a completely different
concept i mean those guys likes the
original members better yeah
there's no way and it's funny you bring
that up
that you know that but there's nothing i
would trade in a million years for the
experience that i've had with these guys
they're brothers they went to school
together but i feel like i'm part of
their family yeah and what we've gone
through together the ups and downs highs
and lows the roller coaster ride has
been a complete blessing i wouldn't
trade it for the world jeff's cousin
eddie in the family jeff's cousin eddie
that's right
i think someone says
jeez give me a little bit more credit
than that
[Laughter]
reached out to you what was his sales
pitch how do you get you on board he he
uh he promised me that we'd be opening
for for james brown and we had this
massive tour lined up so i immediately
packed up my my chrysler the baron and
drove across the country and then got to
la and realized that it was all smoke
and mirrors but we did a lot no i didn't
lie i didn't have a tour lined up that's
been the that's how this thing has
evolved throughout the years no we did
actually open up for james brown we did
and you know some of the other things
might have been a little fudged
no you know what
certain things happen in times in your
life where they just make sense right
any other time in my life maybe that
talking to jeff on the phone i'd have
been like this is absolutely nuts
there's no chance of doing this but for
whatever reason at that point in my life
in that exact moment um it just made
sense and look if he was from ohio
it just made sense on a lot of levels it
felt it felt normal it felt real
and thank god i did i mean look what's
happened since whatever
[Laughter]
later that's amazing uh how does boys to
men fit into all of this and kind of
helping you guys out at the very start i
think for all of us they were our
biggest inspiration we kind of modeled
ourselves after them and they brought
the harmony acapella sound back in such
a strong way that we kind of said well
you know what like we love harmony we
can do it and
we all wanted to give it a try i mean
even before this group justin and i were
in various groups where we would sing
and cover boys domain stuff i know jeff
was you know really inspired by boys to
men when he put the group together
initially it just i think for all of us
of that era i mean if you'd asked
backstreet if you asked i mean boys to
men was the they were kind of the
inspiration
for for all of us in a large way so i
mean the fact that we got to be on
motown records alongside them the fact
that we have had a chance to tour with
them we get to know them since and
i've had a chance to work with sean i
mean it's just it's like it's kind of
surreal we
look back in hindsight and think how
inspired we were by them in fact it was
at their concert that we've met our
first manager and and sung our way
backstage and so
in many different ways they've been a
very very integral part of our of our
career from the very beginning that's
pretty cool listen you guys found such
success at the height of boy bands you
know backstreet boys in sync drew what
do you think of boy bands now
um i mean i think in in a
in a lot of ways regardless of what
genre it is everything's cyclical you
know it all might go away and become
uncool for a little bit but then it's
going to come back around you know
whether it's rock or rap or whatever
whatever it is um i i think for a large
part i mean if you're talking about bts
right now as a boy i mean they they've
achieved a level of success and fame
that is i mean almost unfathomable
unfathomable
it really is i mean the way that you
know they've been able to and and music
in general where they're able to you
know use social media and and youtube
and all these different platforms to
promote themselves
above and beyond what their labels are
doing is something that is uh it's
really kind of hard to get your head
around but you know it's it's such a
different world right now the music
business is than you know 25 years ago
how do you guys feel about playing your
greatest hits do you still love all of
it you have to take breaks with certain
songs do you have love some not love
others i think for us i mean it's unique
every night it sounds cliche or like a
canned answer but different people in
the audience every night when you sing
them right yeah and they're they're
reciprocating their vibe and their
enthusiasm and their energy for you so i
love every song every night that we sing
i'm happy to do it i can express my
gratitude for it
most people try to be cool but i'm not
none of us are clearly the coolest guys
on the planet we're just excited
you are we're excited and happy and
gracious about the opportunity that we
have and it's always a luxury to get up
and do do what we do for a living and
and make a living to do it so well it
was neat too just to piggyback on his
answers that you know doing these songs
25 20 25 years later these songs mean
something to the people who were hearing
them it was it was maybe their first
kiss with their now husband or it was
their wedding song or it was a moment in
high school they remember so you sing
the songs because you love to sing them
and they come because they love to hear
them but there's there's actually a very
a lot of times a deeper meaning it's a
memory it's you're you're taking people
back to a time that that was special to
them to a moment that was special to
them so that's you know not to be like
overly dramatic about it but you know
it's true that's why it never gets old
because it is it's special to somebody
at least every night yeah you're part
part of the soundtrack of their life
yeah i think that's why you guys get
such strong reactions from fans do you
feel that way like this isn't you know i
interview celebrities musicians but i
feel like when you've made an impact on
their lives especially when it comes to
music
people kind of lose themselves around
you guys you guys feel that you know she
said strong reaction
he's always a strong man
now we have the best fans in the world
so we're grateful to have him okay you
guys working on new music
yeah yeah we're constantly writing
recording um you know seeing what our
our new 98 degree sound is going to be
and how it's going to evolve and change
um we have
four or fives songs already recorded
really um yeah we have you know our
we're already like all right so if we
release a single right now what would it
be um yeah so we're definitely working
on the music and i think that's that's
one thing that we never want to do is
just kind of get complacent and just be
like all right
we're going to sing the songs that we
did 25 years ago and that's it yeah um i
think we we constantly want to continue
to grow and evolve and and change uh and
new music is the best way to do that are
there any artists that you're loving
right now that's potentially inspiring
this next chapter of music
well i think some of the artists that
we're inspired by are like throwback
artists that were inspired by the people
that we were inspired by so like bruno
mars and chris brown you know there's a
michael jackson element there's a james
brown element there you know so
you know artists like that are always
you know exciting for us that they're
reinventing the same genre stevie wonder
take off there's john legend who is a
singer songwriter who's that's a very
unique thing right now for us so i think
there are a lot of artists out there
that that inspire us and get us get our
motors going to get back in the studio
and feel like you know we can get back
in there and do our thing
yeah i think ed sheeran is probably the
most talented person on the planet right
now his writing style and his creativity
and his talent are
pretty incredible so i think i think ed
sheeran has a future yeah you should see
yeah if he sticks with it he'll be good
he's doing good um brett kissel our
canadian country boy i love that you
guys collaborated with him what was it
like working with him so brett yeah
brett brett is like the
nicest sweetest human being ever i mean
so for us just to be able to do that
song with him and first of all the song
is a jam i mean it's it's a it's a hit
we first time we heard it we were like
yes we'll absolutely do this song the
hook is just super catchy it's a
well-written song
you know but then you
meet somebody and
they're more than you could hope you
know so it's like all right yeah we'll
do a video we'll do this yeah we'll sing
together we'll collab so it's you know
when you enjoy being around somebody
that you're working with you're
you know open to doing more and more
stuff so um i think for us it's it's a
great great opportunity for us to have
some new music out there in a genre that
isn't necessarily
our own yeah home genre um but we have
great fans in canada so hopefully some
of our
pop fans are going to cross over to this
and hopefully some of his country fans
will cross over to us well we are so
excited that you're coming to calgary in
september to perform at the ccma awards
what can fans expect i know it's gonna
be epic
yeah we're i mean first of all you know
we're excited to perform with brett
perform on on television like that it's
a big big night for him and he's up for
multiple awards and stuff so we're
excited to be a part of that that
experience with him and that journey
with him and um i think the last time we
performed in canada was probably pretty
much music awards you know a few years
back and it was i mean the reception we
got was just incredible
um we've said it before you know our
first gold record was was in canada our
canadian fans have been with us from the
very beginning all the way till now and
so it's it's a special place for us it
always has been always will be so we're
very excited to uh to come back and be a
part of that night with him you're
awesome that's awesome did brett tell
you that he would play 98 degrees songs
to get the attention from the ladies
when he was younger
no i don't think he mentioned that to us
he told me that he was referring to
sorry we play black kissing songs right
now to try and get into it
yeah
you use whatever it means at your
disposal you know listen no pressure but
he gave us all champagne after we
wrapped our interview with him yesterday
so what you guys got for me what you
guys got we don't have anything we have
guys and we usually come to the bar
it's on ice it's it's in there it's a
little hot out here so we kept that we
got you we're gonna figure this out
i believe in you guys uh who else would
you love to collab like you've done
brett kessel it's such a good song who
else is like on your list
man i mean i think like bruno mars you
know to us it's he has such a kind of
throwback sound that would be that would
be an awesome collaboration um you know
i can't listen to an adele song without
like feeling
every emotion known to man so i would
lose it if you collaborated with i'm
getting kind of jealous of all these
elton john collabs right all right i
would love to i love to collaborate with
you i sat next to elton at the gq
awards i remember he offered me a mento
really because i met my brother
or whether he was just taking one for
himself and just you know
very nicely listen it's a great story
it's one of my it's one of my favorite
memories
one of my favorite memories no big deal
uh going back to brad kissel who would
make the best cowboy in real life out of
all four of you well i think drew yeah i
mean he really he's already ready to
pipe up without us he has cowboy boots
he already drives a pickup truck okay
you're getting he he works around the
house he's good with his hands
yeah that's true yeah save a horse ride
a cowboy yeah i spent a summer on a
horse ranch yeah i love this okay
speaking of us being in such a beautiful
place here at beaches tricks and caicos
what is your guilty pleasure on vacation
just go
i think me just relaxing which is really
hard for me to do we're in this business
that's always on the go so sitting back
taking a deep breath enjoying the beach
the scenery that kind of stuff is my
guilty pleasure for sure
uh mine are probably frozen blended
drinks with an umbrella nice can only
get away with that on vacation right and
it looks cool yeah my i honestly i don't
drink that much normally
but on vacation it just seems it goes
down so much easier right you know when
you know that you don't have to you know
drive somewhere pick the kids up from
school do something like so yeah just
you know just being able to relax have a
nice cold beer i love that i usually
stay away from sweets but when you're on
vacation sometimes you just gotta throw
caution in the wind exactly
calories don't count here a lot of
sweets around here there's a lot of food
it's so good you guys had cinnamon rolls
for breakfast donuts i mean it's tough